راويه وطاهر شكرا جزيلا لكما بالفعل اذا
مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في تغطيه المعارك
المتواصله في السودان لليوم الثالث على
التوالي اذا والتي تسببت حتى الان بمقتل
نحو 100
شخصا واصابه اكثر من
1800 جريح في صفوف المدنيين وفقا لارقام
امميه صراع يصر ان لا يهدا حتى الان رغم
المناشدات الدوليه والمحليه والانسانيه
الا ان اصوات المدافع والرصاص والغارات
اقوى من تلك المناشدات على ما يبدو
[تصفيق]
نظام
وين الدعم
[موسيقى]
هذا وقلا يوسف عزه المستشار السياسي
ولقائد قوات الدعم السريع للعربيه ان
المعركه مع قوات الجيش ستكون فاصله خاصه
وان قوات الدعم السريع اصبحت تسيطر على
كافه المباني والمقر الرئيسيه اضافه الى
مطار الخرطوم
لكن التوقيت الان بالنسبه للمبادرات نحن
نرحب بكل مبادره لكن الان المعرفه تدور
الان وانا اتحدث معك كمان المعرفه
هنالك
توقيت مثل هذه المبادرات لكن الان الوقت
للماركه ونحن ندخل معركه فاصله مع
الانقلابيين مع الاسلاميين مع الذين
اختطفوا القرار في الجيش نحن نسيطر الان
على القياده العامه بالكامل بكل مبانيها
وخارج اسوارها نحن متواجدين نسيطر على
مطار الخرطوم نسيطر على القصر الرئاسي
نسيطر على ايدائها ربنا ايذاء الاذاعه
والتلفزيون نسيطر على قائد سيدنا الجويه
نسيطر على جبل اولياء نسيطر على كل
المداخل الكباري المؤديه الى ولايه
الخرطوم الى مدينه الخرطوم
في المقابل نفى العميد نبيل عبد الله
الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني للعربيه ايضا
نفى ادعاءات قوات الدعم السريع بالسيطره
على اجزاء من مبنى القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه والقصر الجمهوري وقصر الضيافه
نؤكد انه لا صح اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره ميليشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مقرات القياده العامه
ولا على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر
الجمهوري هذه اساليب مضلله الامر الثاني
نحن نؤكد اننا القوات المسلحه لاننا قوات
محترفه وقوات مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم تماما
بجميع قواعد الاشتباك في مثل هذه الحالات
نحن نتغير تماما بمقررات القانون الدولي
الانساني قانون النزاعات المسلحه في هذا
النزاع المسلح
هذا واعلنت قوات الدعم السريع في فيديو
نشرته على صفحتها على تويتر سيطرتها على
صواريخ في مخازن حربيه تابعه للجيش
السوداني فيما نفى الجيش ما اعلن عنه
الدعم السريع حول استلائهم على معدات
وصواريخ مؤكدا ان ما كل ما يحتويه المخزن
تالف وغير قابل للاستخدام
[موسيقى]
ونبدا المتابعه الميدانيه معنا الان
الصحفي السوداني خالد الفكي مباشره من
الخرطوم خالد اهلا اطلعتنا على خارطه
المعارك بين الدعم السريع والجيش في هذه
الساعه بالتحديد
نعم يعني على حسب المعلومات المتوفره لدي
انه ما زالت هناك اشتباكات في حي الجبره
بين القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
وانه ربما هناك تكون قوه من الدعم السريع
ايضا حاولت استرداد مقرها ومحاوله العضله
مجددا فبالتالي يعني قبل اقل من عشر دقائق
كنا نسمع اصوات للذخيره الحيه الثقيله
ربما تكون هي مدفعيه او هناك او راجمات
حتى يعني كلنا نشعر بذلك في المنازل التي
هي في محيط الدبره ودائره الاشتباكات مما
يجي بان المعارك والمطالبات والملاحظات
مازال مستمره في اكثر من منطقه في الخرطوم
وان كانت استراتيجيه القدم المسلحه التي
قال بها الناطق الرسمي
نعم يعني اعتقد انه الان في ظل هذه
الاوضاع من الطبيعي جدا ان ينتهي كل طرف
بانه حاجه ويسيطر على موقع حقيقي
واستراتيجي في ظل عدم قدره
المراقبين والصحفيين على الوصول الى اغرب
نقطه بسبب الاشتباكات الممتده والتي
تستخدم فيها كافه انواع الاسلحه الصغيره
وايضا بسبب الحواجز الامنيه وانتشار
المدرعات والاليات فبالتالي اعتقد انه
يصعب التحقق والتحري من مدى صدريه كل طرف
بانه الان يحوز والان لو يد على موقع
استراتيجي هنا وهناك فبالتالي حتى تنتهي
الامور ونستطيع
التحرير على ارض الميدان يمكن الفصل حينه
ولكن الان الطبيعي جدا في ظل الحرب
النفسيه والحرب الاعلانيه
في مجال الصحافه
دعنا نتحدث عن وضعيه الاعلام التلفزيون
الرسمي من يسيطر عليه
ايضا هذه واحده من الاشكاليات التي حتى
الان لا نستطيع الجزم فيها نعم نعم لانه
الان مبنى التلفزيون الهيئه العامه هو في
دائره الاشتباك والعمليات دل على حسب
المعلوماتيك
في التلفزيون قال بان بان احد الساكنين
والقاطني بالقربي من مقر التلفزيون اتم
اخبارهم بضروره
الابتعاد من هذه في هذه الايام من
التلفزيون ربما يكون هذا يجي بان القوات
المسلحه ربما كانت لها نوايا
خوضي معركه وادغام الدعم السريع الذي يقول
انه داخل مضنه التلفزيون الذي قطع الارسال
والذي كان موجود في غرفه البث وربما فشل
فيها مما اضطر الفنيين يعني استخدام
غناء بديله للدرس الان يعني وضع الاعلام
يعني يمكن ان اكمل الفكره الامين
السودانيين في ظل هذه الظروف هو يعني عدم
القدره على التحقق من المعلومات وايصال
المعلومات او حتى الاتصال بالمصادر
الرسميه سواء كان في الدعم السريع او
القوات المسلحه
المعلومات بشكل مباشر هناك صعوبه
وعدم يعني عدم الحصول على المعلومه في هذا
المواقيت ارجو ان تبقى معي نعم الصوره
تبقى ضبابيه نعم وحقيقه ما يحصل يمكن ان
تثبت معها بعد ان تتوقف المعارك اذا
مشاهدينا نشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل الان
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي يتراس
اجتماعا للمجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
المصريه لا نعلم اذا كان هذا الاجتماع اذا
مرتبط بالاحداث الجاريه الان في السودان
وكذلك اذا كان سيناقش كذلك مساله الجنود
المصريين الذين كانوا متواجدين في السودان
اثناء طبعا بدايه هذه المعارك بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني اذا الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي الان يتراس
اجتماعا للمجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
المصريه ايضا مشاهدينا نواصل في هذه
التغطيه مع الان هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور
اسامه احمد المص الكاتب والمحلل في الشؤون
الافريقيه دكتور اسامه اهلا بك معنا الى
هذه التغطيه من العربيه اليوم نحن في
اليوم الثالث من المواجهات بين الدعم
السريع والجيش
احاديث المسؤولين من الدعم السريع والجيش
العربي كل يدعي في روايته انه يسيطر على
المواقع الحيويه في الخرطوم هذا التضارب
في الروايات لثلاثه ايام عما ينبئ كيف
يمكن قراءته نعم هذا
بالتاكيد هو الترويج اعلامي الظهور بشكل
يبين
كل طرف من الاطراف يؤكد على انه هو مسيطر
على الوضع هذه بالتاكيد هو
محاوله استئصال بادوار قدر من
التاييد الشعبي باعتبار النقوات الدعم
السريعه الان هي
بشكل مباشر استطاعت ان تتعامل مع الاعلام
وتفرط نفسها كما نرى في تصريحات القوات
المسلحه الان وضعها صعب جدا لانها لم
تستطيع ان تروج بشكل جيد كما تفعل قوات
الدعم السريعه وهذه هي المفارقه
الدعم السريع متفوق في الترويج على الجيش
يعني في الترويج الانتصارات ربما تعتقد
نعم بشكل هذه الانتصارات تعتقد انها ليست
حقيقيه لا استطيع ان اجزم بذلك خاصه وانا
يعني ما اعرفه المستشار
عبد الله امين السيد محمد حمدان الذي تحدث
عن السيطره الدعم
هو حسب معرفتي ولا اجزم بانه يكذب او لا
يكذب ولكنه ليس موجود في الخرطوم هو موجود
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حسب معرفته
ان كان صحيحا هو موجود في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ويقول هذا الكلام معنى
هذا الكلام غير دقيق من شخص خارج نطاق
الموقع الحدث
القوات العسكريه ايضا الناطق الرسمي ايضا
يتحدث بان نعم نعم يتحدث عن انه القوات
المسلحه مسيطره على كل المواقع فيما
المفارقه في انه الطرفين المصداقيه ليست
مؤكده تماما في المرحله الحاليه وهذه هي
دكتور اسامه عن الرئيس السوداني انا منذ
بدايه يعني هذا هذه الاشتباكات المسلحه
احاول ان اعرف اكبر قدر من اراء
السودانيين حياه لما يجري الراي العام
السوداني مع من في الوقت الرهن الرايز
العام السوداني لا استطيع ان اجزم بانه
منقسم ولكن هنالك لاي طرف
بما ان قوات الشعب المسلحه هي قوات تسمى
قوات شعب مسلحه معنا هي قوات الشعب
السوداني يميل الى القوات المسلحه اكثر من
قوات الدعم السريع لانه قوات الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت قوات الدعم السريع ما يهمني ان
تكون حياه افضل واستقرار افضل في السودان
هل تعتقد ان هذا الراي هو سائد يعني انه
في نهايه سودانيون يعني لا يهمهم من الطرف
المنتصر بل يهمهم الطرف الذي يكون يحقق
الاستقرار
الى حد ما هذا الكلام ممكن يكون الصواب
باعتبار انه الثوره التي قامت منذ عام
2019 كان يعني الثوره فيها سلميه من اجل
الديمقراطيه من اجل السلام من اجل التنميه
من اجل الاستقرار من النهضه والانفتاح
للعالم
من يحقق هذا الامر في واقع الامر هو الذي
سيلتف حوله الشعب والان كما نعلم
محمد حمدان هو بيصرح بانه هو مع
الديمقراطيه ومع المدنيه فيما البرهان حتى
الان لم لم يشير لهذا الامر بشكل واضح
بالتالي المفارقه تبقى في انه الشارع
السوداني يعرف انه هذه قوات المسلحه هي
قوات في وقت من الاوقات قناه كانت تابعه
لفئه معينه
ويعني حزب معين قوات الدعم السريع بالنسبه
لهم هم قوات جهويه او من جهه اخرى
فبالتالي المفارقه بتبقى قائمه انه الشعب
لن يستطيع ان يجزم مع من سيكون دكتور ارجو
ان تبقى معنا سعودي اليك لمتابعه البعد
الافريقي والعربي كذلك والدولي في مسعا
لوقف هذا الاقتتال مشاهدينا نعود ونذكر
بالخبر العاجل البارز الذي ورد خلال هذه
الساعه اجتماع الرئيس السيسي وتراسه اذا
اجتماع اجتماع للمجلس الاعلى للدوله
للقوات المسلحه المصريه طبعا لا نعلم اذا
كان سيناقش موضوع هذه التطورات في السودان
طبعا ومساله الجنود المصريين الموجودين في
الخرطوم كذلك جوزيف بوريل يقول ان
الاعتداء على سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي في
السودان انتهاءكم صارخ لاتفاق يه فيينا
اذا
نذهب اذن نبقى في المتابعه لا اعلم اذا
كان هناك المزيد من المعطيات رشحت فيما
يتعلق بتراس الرئيس السيسي اجتماع المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه المصريه على العموم
سنتابع هذا الخبر العجل والمزيد من
تفاصيله نذهب الى الصور المباشره التي
تاتينا من الخرطوم ونلقي نظره اذا عليها
اذا المشاهدين لليوم الثالث على التوالي
اذا الاشتباكات والمعارك الضاريه مستمره
في السودان طبعا رائحه البارود تشتم بشكل
واسع في شوارع السودان في اليوم الثالث من
المعارك بين قوات الدعم السريع بقياده
محمد حمدان والمعروف اعلاميا باسم حمتي
والجيش السوداني برئاسه عبد الفتاح
البرهان طبعا الحصيله حسب الارقام الامميه
هي تناهز المئتي قتيل واكثر من 1800 جريح
طبعا اليوم كانت هناك جلسه لمجلس الامن
وتحدث فيها رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده في
السودان وتحدث في مداخله عبر الفيديو امام
مجلس الامن الدولي في الجلسه مغلقه وقال
ان الوضع في السودان صعب جدا وان الحصيله
هي 180 قتيل حتى الان
طبعا هناك حاله ذعر ما تزال مستمره هناك
في السودان اذا ونعود الان الى المواقف
الدوليه كذلك ممثله السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي وزير قال ان السفير
الاتحاد في السودان تعرض الاعتداء في مقر
اقامته قبل بضع ساعات دون ذكر تفاصيل حول
طبيعه الاعتداء او المهاجمين المحتملين
بوريل اضافه عبر حسابه على تويتر ان
الاعتداء يشكل انتهاكا صارخا لاتفاقيات
فيينا مشيرا الى ان امن المنشات والموظفين
الدبلوماسيين مسؤوليه اساسيه للسلطات
السودانيه والتزام
بالقانون الدولي
هذا وافدت مصادر من السفاره الامريكيه
للعربيه بان قوه الدعم السريع استهدفت عن
قصد عربه مصفحه تابعه للسفاره الامريكيه
باطلاق نحو 100 رصاصه عليها واضافت
المصادر ان استهداف المصفحه لم يسفر عن
وقوع قتلى او اصابات
معنى من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم هل هناك اي مستجدات ميدانيه
جديده وكذلك اي معطيات اضافيه حول استهداف
سياره السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم وكذلك
استهداف ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي
بهذه الاستهدافات ربما تذهب هذه الحرب الى
منعطف اخطر من ما كان عليه من قبل هذا
المنعطف الخطير الذي سيدخل ايضا ربما
مشاركين او متضررين اخرين من هذه الحرب
ليس السودانيون وحدهم من تضرروا من هذه
الحرب وهذا منعطف ربما يكون خطوه اعلى من
التي هي عليها الان هنا في الخرطوم العديد
من الاضرار العديد من
الاشكاليات العديد من الامور التي هي غير
واضحه بالنسبه للمواطن اننا الان تحدثت
باسم المواطن السوداني وهو ينظر الى هذه
الاحداث والتسارعها كذلك نتحدث في الجانب
الانساني كذلك ان هنالك العديد من
المستشفيات الخارجيه الان
ايضا في الزيارات الميداليه لهذه
المستشفيات العديد من العقبات التي تحكم
دون استمرار المستشفيات في تقديم الخدمات
العلاجيه اللازمه للمصابين والمرضى وحتى
المعتادين مثلا
الامراض عفوا الامراض الروتينيه مثل غسيل
الكلى الذي يعاني اصحابه هذه الايام
بالتواجد مركز يقوم بهذه المهمه على اكمل
وجه في ظل انقطاع المياه وكذلك
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي كذلك في بعض
الاحياء وبعض المستشفيات كذلك يضيف الى
ذلك استهداف لبعض المستشفيات كان واضحا في
مستشفى ابن سينا وايضا استهداف كذلك
لمستشفى بحري التخصصي والان مستشفى بحري
هو خارج الخدمه تماما ولا يستقبل اي حالات
حتى هذه اللحظه عدم قدره الكوادر الطبيه
للوصول للمستشفيات كل هذه الامور ذكرت ان
رائحه البارود تشم في الخرطوم ولكن الاخطر
ان الموت بدات تشم كذلك في كثير
هذا البارود نعم نعم حصيله كبيره جدا وهي
قابله للزياده بكل تاكيد مع الاسف واقول
مع الاسف لان هذه المناظر التي رايناها في
المستشفيات سواء من المصابين او من الجثث
الموجوده التي لم يستطيع ايصالها لا
للمشارح ولا لذويها
ساعود اليك عدم القدره الى هذا الخبر
العاجل الان اذا مشاهدينا كما توقعنا قبل
قليل وعطفا على العاجل الذي اوردناه عن
تراس رئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
لاجتماع المجلس القوات المسلحه الان
مراسله العربيه تقول ان اجتماع مجلس
القوات المسلحه المصريه برئاسه السيسي
يبحث وضع الجنود المصريين في السودان اذا
هذا ما توقعناه الان المزيد من التفاصيل
ترشح حول تراوس الرئيس السيسي اذا لاجتماع
مجلس القوات المسلحه ويبحث تامين عوده
الجنود المصريين من السودان للتذكير مع
اندلاع هذه الاشتباكات ثلاثه ايام ما بين
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني كانت هناك
مجموعه من الجنود السودانيين جرى يعني
احتجازهم من قبل قوات الدعم السريع حسب
الاخبار وحسب تصريحات كذلك قوات الدعم
السريع قالت ان هؤلاء الجنود المصريين
يعاملون معامله جيده وانهم في الحفظ
والصون الان هناك يعني تحرك مصري في هذا
الاجتماع برئاسه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
اذا لمناقشه التامين عوده هؤلاء الجنود
المصريين هذا التطور كذلك لافت في هذه
الازمه في السودان ببعد مع الجاره مصر
كذلك سنتابع ايضا
مالاته والعلي هنا اعود الى ضيفي هنا في
الاستوديو الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه
دكتور اسامه اعود اليك كيف يمكن التعليق
على هذا الاعلان الان الاجتماعي للرئيس
المصري لمجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
وكيف ترى
بشكل مباشر هل برايك مصر الان ستدخل
في هذا الصراع في السودان نعم هذا
الاجتماع كان متوقع ان يحدث
والتحرك المصري نحو
اخراج القوات العسكريه المصريه الموجوده
في مطار مروي كانوا متوقعا متوقع ان يكون
هناك تحرك من هذا القبيل وايضا التصريح
الذي اتى من قوات الدعم السريع بانه هؤلاء
الجنود في الحفظ والصون ويمكن وايضا
المستشار الذي تحدث عن انه هنالك تواصل مع
الاداره المصريه فيما يتعلق باعادتهم الى
الى مصر قد يكون هو وحدي من الاسباب التي
تم هذه الاجتماع وربما حتى تصريحات الدعم
السريع لا تذهب باتجاه انه ان يكون فيها
نبره عدائيه تجاه مصر صحيح وهذا ما اتوقع
انه المرحله باتجاه الحل ليس باتجاه
التازيم يعني الدخول المصري على الخط يعني
ربما هو الاستلام جنوده بكل امان يعني حتى
المعلقين السياسيين والمحللين السياسيين
المصريين كلهم يتحدثوا بنبره
التصالح او عدم يعني اشعال المساله لتتحول
الى ازمه ما بين مصر وبين السودان هذه
المرحله صعبه طيب ارجو ان تبقى معنا دكتور
على العموم معي الان مباشره مراسلتنا رنده
ابو العزم مباشره من القاهره رنده اسالك
عما وصلت اليه في الحديث مع الدكتور اسامه
الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه هل هناك ازمه
بين مصر والسودان قادمه
حتى الان لا يوجد اي ازمات ولكن هناك
مساعي مصريه لنزع فتيل الازمه ولا ايقاف
اطلاق النيران هناك مبادرات مصريه اطلقها
الرئيس السيسي منذ اول يوم
وبالامس هناك مشاهد دبلوماسيه بنراها من
خلال اتصالات وزير الخارجيه وايضا بالامس
كان هناك اجتماع طارق في الجامعه العربيه
على مستوى المندوبين اذا النصر بتعمل في
اكثر من مسار مسار الدبلوماسيه مسار ايقاف
اطلاق النيران ونزلته الازمه ولكن بتعلم
صهيب بان
الرئيس السيسي اجتمع اليوم بالمجلس الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه
يعني بحسب بعض المعلومات التي رشحت من
مصادر ان هذا الاجتماع جاء لتقييم الوضع
بشكل كامل وبدا خطوره الاوضاع في السودان
على مصر تعلم ان السودان هي عمق استراتيج
عذرا على المقاطعه طبعا هذه هي فقط
المعلومات نحن اوردنا عواجل نقلا عنك طبعا
فتنا به طبعا عن اجتماع الرئيس السيسي مع
المجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه لكن ماذا
نعرف عن الجنود المصريين الموجودين في
السودان لماذا هناك جنود مصريين اساسا في
السودان وكم عددهم الان واين هم محتجزون
صهيب اذا تابعت منذ اليوم الاول كان هناك
بيان للمتحدث العسكري ان كان هناك مناورات
مشتركه بين
قوات وبين قوات
معتاد
سواء من السودان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مصر بتقوم زادت جدا عدد مناوراتها
العسكريه برا وبحرا وجوا مع عدد كبير من
الدول في الخمس سنوات الاخيره اذا هذه
القوات كانت متواجده بصوره
معلومه بصوره تدريب ومناورات يعني مناورات
مشتركه مع الجيش السوداني تدريب مشترك
وكان معلن عنه وهذا ايضا جاء في اول بيان
ذكره المتحدث العسكري هناك تقييم كما ذكرت
على مدار الساعه من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه
المصريه واسياديه تم مناقشه وضع الجنود
والافراد المصريين حتى هذه اللحظه
والقاهره بتعمل حاليا على سلامه الجنود
المصريين والعمل على تامين عودتهم بحسب ما
علمنا صهيب وهذه نقطه مهمه ان القاهره
ستطرح خطوات خلال الساعات القادمه لوقف
اطلاق نيران قبل عيد الفطر اذا هذه
المعلومات من مصادرنا
ونحن نعلم ان الجنود المصريين هناك عمل في
اكثر من مسار تامين عوده الجنود المصريين
الذين كانوا يشاركون في تدريبات مشتركه
بالصوم سالمين الى مصر وفي الوقت ذاته نزع
فتيل الازمه ووقف اطلاق النيران ثم بعد
ذلك تاتي الخطوات الاخرى لان مصر ايضا
كانت منخرطه في العمليه في استضافه
الفصائل السودانيه لحل المشكله
بصوره سياسيه قبل تفاقم الاوضاع راندا
ذكرتي انه اجتماع الرئيس السيسي بالمجلس
العالي للقوات المسلحه ناقشه وضع الجنود
المصريين وتقييم الوضع كذلك حسب خبرتك
يعني عندما تستخدم هذه المصطلحات بمعنى ان
الجنود او وضعيه ملف هؤلاء الجنود
المصريين في طريقه للحل ام هو ملف معقد او
ربما هناك مفاوضات يعني متعسره لاعادتهم
سالمين الى مصر لا يتم الحديث عن اي
مفاوضات حتى هذه يعني لحظه العمليه بتقوم
اذا كان هناك مفاوضات فهي تقوم بصوره سريه
ولا يمكن الاعلان عنها ولكن نعلم انها
اولويه واولويه لمصر سعاده الجنود
المصريين في اقرب وقت وبالتالي
يعني ربما سنجد في غضون الساعات او حتى
اليوم القادم انفراجه في هذه الازمه لانها
بتشكل بالفعل ازمه وليس فقط على مستوى
قياده ولكن على مستوى الشارع المصري لان
كان هناك استياء من الفيديو الذي تم
اذاعته حتى وان كان هناك اعتذار عنه ولكن
كان هناك استياء في الشارع المصري من هذا
الفيديو شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعطيات المهمه اذا مديره مكتب بالعربيه
في القاهره رنده ابو العزم شكرا لك حتى
الان ولكن
سنتواصل معك تباعا لموافاتنا باي تفاصيل
ترشح عن هذا الاجتماع المهم للرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي بالمجلس الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه المصريه اذا ومناقشه يعني ملف
الجنود المصريين الموجودين في السودان طيب
اذا وكما ذكرت مديره مكتبنا في القاهره
اذا مصر تستعد اذن
طرح وساطه او خطه لوقف اطلاق النار قبل
عيد الفطر يعني عيد يعني باقي ايام قليله
دكتور اسامه هنا اسالك هل تعتقد يعني
شاهدنا الكثير من المبادرات الافريقيه
العربيه
كذلك الامميه برايك هل يعني
هذه المبادره المصريه الجديده التي تتحدث
عنها مديره مكتبنا في القاهره لديها فرصه
للنجاح طبعا الى حد ما نحن الان يعني يمكن
مبادرةةة هي متوافقه مع مبادره جنوب
السودان الرئيس جنوب السودان وهي مبادره
قد تكون الى درجه كبيره من من
التحرك الصحيح باعتبار انه الطرفين لهم
تاثير قوي على القيادتين قياده
البرهان والسيد محمد حمدان الطرفين او
الطرفان
حكومه المصريه وحكومه جنوب السودان لديهم
التاثير الممكن يصلوا الى ان يرفعوا مستوى
مدام هذا التاثير موجود لماذا لم يستجب اي
من الطرفين يعني على مدار ثلاثه ايام وكما
نتابع يعني رائحه البارود والموت كما ذكر
مراسلنا باتت تشتم الان يوميا في شوارع
الخرطوم لان المبادره كانت مجرد كلام يعني
فكره طرحت ولن تتحرك لم يتحرك الحكومه
جنوب السودان وحكومه المصريه بشكل جاد الا
خلال اليوم اليوم هو اليوم الذي تم التحرك
فيه بشكل جاد ولكن ايضا لابد من تحرك
داخلي للاحزاب السياسيه وقوات اسميهم اللي
هم مجموعه
الحركات المسلحه الموجوده بقياده
لابد ان يتحركوا ايضا يكونوا كنت حاورت
يعني يعني متحدث باسم العدو والمساوات
وقال انهم في بدايه الدكتور يعني تواصلوا
مع الفريقين ولكن ايضا لا يوجد هناك
استجابه حتى من التحركات الداخليه لا توجد
هناك استجابه لماذا برايك لانه الطرفين في
في كان الاحتقان عالي جدا بين الطرفين
الان بعد الانفجار بكل التاكيد الطرفان
يبحثان عن
مساحه للخروج من هذه الازمه اعتبار الخروج
منتصرين ربما ربما منتصرين ولكن الخروج من
الازمه بشكل عام الازمه تفاقمت والمتضرر
الكل والشعب السوداني هو اكثر من يتضرر في
هذا الدكتور اسامه ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء
معنا اذا مشاهدينا نبقى في متابعه اذا
امتدادات هذه الازمه في السودان كما تبعنا
قبل قليل مع مصر واجتماع الرئيس السيسي
بالمجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه كذلك نتحدث
عن الاتحاد الاوروبي حيث قال ممثل السياسه
الخارجيه في اتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفوريل ان
سفير الاتحاد في السودان تعرض لاعتداء في
مقر اقامته قبل بضع ساعات دون ذكر تفاصيل
حول طبيعه الاعتداء او المهاجمين
المحتملين واضافها بريال عبر حسابه على
تويتر ان الاعتداء يشكل انتهاكا صارخا
لاتفاقيه فيينا مشيرا الى ان امن المنشاه
والموظفين الدبلوماسيين مسؤوليه اساسيه
للسلطات السودانيه والتزام بموجب القانون
الدولي
امريكيا ايضا افادت مصادره من السفاره
الامريكيه للعربيه بان قوات الدعم السريع
استهدفت عن قصد عربه مصفحه تابعه
للسفاره الامريكيه باطلاق نحو 100 رصاصه
عليها واضافت المصادر ان استهداف المصافحه
لم يسفر عن وقوع قتلى او اصابات
الى مراسلنا في بروكسل نور الدين الفريضي
نور الدين اهلا بك معنا هل توافرت اي
معلومات اضافيه حول ما حل بالسفير
الاوروبي في الخرطوم
اهلا سهيل لا النزال ننتظر تفاصيل من
الجانب الاوروبي حول ما وصفه جوزيف بوريل
في تغريدته بالاعتداء على السفير في مقره
اقامته لنعلم في هذه اللحظه هل هناك اضرار
وخسائر بشريه هل اصيب السفيره هل اصيب
طاقم السفير او من معه او فقط
المقر كمبنى لا نزلنا ننتظر
يعني رد او تفاصيل من الجانب الرسمي
الاوروبي هنا
هذا الاعتداء ياتي
المزيد من التفاصيل
قبل ان نذهب الى موضوع امريكا كذلك كيف هي
المواقف في اوروبا حيال هذا الصراع
المتفجر الان منذ ثلاثه ايام في السودان
الموقف الاوروبي او المواقف الاوروبيه
ربما توجد في اولا ادانه اعمال العنف التي
تفجرت بين القوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع ثانيا دعوه الاطراف
اطراف النزاع الى التحفظ والى الجلوس الى
طاوله الحوار وقفي العمليات العدائيه فورا
ثم هناك قلق اوروبي حقيقيه من تداعيات هذه
الحرب على صعيد المن على السودان قبل كل
شيء وعلى صعيد المنطقه ككل ورابعا ان هذا
العنف المتفجر الان ربما
سيقضي نهائيا على خطه اتفاقيه الاطار
السياسي التي ربما يعني ستطوى صفحتها فتره
ما هذا هو الموقف اذا صح صحه اجازته في
بشكل سريع هذا المساء نعم طيب سامحني نور
الدين قاطعتك في كنت تود الحديث ربما على
موضوع ايضا الاعتداء على السياره تابعه
للسفاره الامريكيه كذلك في الخرطوم
يعني هناك احتمال من ان الاعتداء على مقر
السفير الاوروبي وعلى السفير الاوروبي لا
نعلم الان التفاصيل الاعتداء على البعثه
على سياره البعث الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
ربما هناك طرف من الاطراف النزاع في
الميدان يريد ويسعى الى جر الاطراف
الخارجيه الى النزاع حتى وان كان على
الصعيد الرسمي الاتحاد الاوروبي في
اتصالاته جوزيف بوريل مع عدد من المسؤولين
والوزراء وزير خارجيه مصر وزير خارجيه
الامارات الرئيس كينبي بصفته رئيس ايجاد
وكذلك اطراف دوليه اخرى منها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه يدعو هذه الاطراف الى
التحفظ عن التدخل المباشر فهناك ربما
شهاده تسعى الى توريك اطراف خارجيه في هذا
النزاع لان لهذا النزاع مثلما اسلفت هناك
تداعيات كبيره جدا داخل السودان وتداعيات
بالنسبه للمحيط من البحر الاحمر والقرن
الافريقي حتى منطقه الساحل الافريقي
وتداعيتها
سواء كان على مصر على شمال افريقيا وعلى
اوروبا بصفه عامه
شكرا جزيلا لك من بروكسل
هذا ونقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني والقائد العام للجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان قوله ان الهجوم الذي شنته
قوات دعم السريع في الايام الاخيره هو
محاوله انقلاب واضاف البرهان ان قائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو تمرد ضد
الدوله واذا تم القبض عليه فستتم محاكمته
امام القطع
وفي المقابل ايضا قال قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو اي حميدتي ان قوته
تتخذ جميع الاجراءات اللازمه لضمان امن
وسلامه المدنيين وطالب حميتي عبر سلسله
تغريدات على حسابه في تويتر طالب المجتمع
الدولي بالتحرك الفوري والتدخل ضدما
اسمائها بجرائم رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
معنا من الخرطومه اللواء الدكتور امين
اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
بمركز الدراسات الدوليه سياده اللواء اهلا
بك معنا في هذه التغطيه من العربيه اريد
في البدايه قراءتك لو سمحت لاستهداف
السفير الاوروبي في منزله في الخرطوم
وكذلك استهداف السياره التابعه للبعثه
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه في الخرطوم كذلك هل
هناك طرف يحاول توسيع دائره هذا الصراع
بين الدعم السريع والجيش
مساء الخير ومرحبا بك ومرحبا بالساده
المشاهدين
حقيقه هذه اخبار مؤسفه ويبدو
ان هذا عمل ممنهج وبالتالي هنالك من يريد
ان يبعد المجتمع الدولي من التوسط او
الدخول لحل هذه الازمه وبالتالي
يوضح ان هنالك فوضى في السودان وهنالك قال
الامن
هذا العمل سيؤثر تاثير كبير جدا على تفاعل
العالم مع الازمه في السودان
وهذه الامور هي التي تعود الى الحرب
الاهليه وتعود الى توسيع هذا الصراع او
وبالتالي يجب حسني مثل هذه التصرفات
وتوفير الحمايه للاخوه باحساده الرئيسيه
وفي المنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه دكتور
امين من تعتقد اي من الفريقين يسعى الى
توسيع دائ ره يعني الاستهدافات لتشمل
بعثات اجنبيه في السودان
هو طبعا يزعم لا عن تحديد اي طرف لكن
نستبعد نظريه المؤامره انا اعتقد انه قد
يكون تصرف من افراد في حاله عدم ضبط
للقوات بدون تنسيق مع غياداتهم
وبالتالي
يمكن هنا القبول بعرض التصرف لكن لابد
ايضا من معرفه من المتسبب وتوفير الحمايات
حتى لا يكون هنالك طلب الان بدل الناس
تتدخل لحل الازمه السودانيه يكون هنالك
طلب لمعرفه من هو الذي اعتدى وبالتالي
تضيع الجهود الدوليه اباء ويستمر الصراعا
نعم طيب سيره اللواء قبل قليل كانت معنا
مديره مكتبنا في القاهره وتحدثت عن تحرك
مصري يعني حتى يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق النار
في السودان بين الطرفين قبل عيد الفطر
المبارك
هل تعتقد ان هناك فرصه لكي ينتهي الصراع
وهذه المعارك على الاقل المواجهات المسلحه
ان تنتهي هذه او تتوقف النيران قبل عيد
الفطر
واحده من الاشكاليات الان
على الارض كيف سيصل هؤلاء الوسطاء الان
المطار يحتاج على الاقل الى اسبوع
بالامس تدم الاعتداء على مستودعات الوقود
وما زالت النيران مشتعله وبالتالي لابد من
تجهيز المطار اولا وحمايته حتى لا يحدث
الاعتداء مثلما حدث بالنسبه للسفير
الامريكي
الاخوه في الامم المتحده
التجهيز المطار الاتصال ايضا بالغاده الان
قبل الوصول الى الخرطوم هنالك ايضا
بحساب من الايجات فيها ثلاثه رؤساء تريد
ان تصل الى الخرطوم الجانب المصري طبعا له
علاقه مع اطراف الازمه في السودان
هو الاقرب لنفسيه الشعب السوداني المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ايضا
لديها رغبه في التوسط وكان هناك تصريح
ايجابي ممتاز جدا من وزير الخارجيه
السعودي انا اعتقد انه
تحدثنا عن توقيت قبلي عيد الفطر عيد الفطر
طبقات
يجب على الجميع ان ينصعوا داخليا غاده
المكونات العسكريه يجب ان يكون لديك يعني
الحقيقه اليوم من تصريحات حميتي وتصريحات
البرهان يعني واضح انه كل طرف يرى من
زاويته فقط ويرى في الطرف الاخر على انه
يجب ان يحاكم هل تعتقد انه ما زالت هناك
فرصه لحل هذه الازمه عن طريق التفاوض
دي طبعا السعاده الاخيره قبل التفاوض او
الدقائق قبل التفاوض كله طلب بيحاول يقوي
موهبه
ويحاول ان يدخل الى التفاوض وهو في موقف
قوي وبالتالي يضع خصمه في زاويه ضيقه لكن
الرغبه موجوده ومساله الحسم العسكري كما
راينا مع تطاول الايام وتطاول الساعات قد
تاخذ وقتها اطول وخسائر اكبر طيب هنا
دكتور امين يعني انت خبير في مجال الامن
كيف يفسر هناك من يقول انه قوات الدعم
السريع يعني هي لا تقارن من حيث القوه
والعدد والعتاد لا تقارن بالجيش النظامي
السوداني فكيف يعني يستمر هذا الهجوم
لثلاثه ايام متتاليه وهناك انباء متضاربه
حول سيطره الدعم السريع على مواقع حيويه
منها المقر المقر القياده العامه للجيش
كيف يمكن ان يحصل هذا
طبعا
الخطابات وتصريحات التي تريد فيها في اطار
الحرب النفسيه واعتقد انه تاكد لكم انتم
في هذه القناه ان كثير منها غير صحيح اما
الفتره الزمنيه
معلوم انه قوات الدعم سريع تم تسليحها
وتقويتها من قبل النظام السابق وفي
العامين الماضيين ودخلت في علاقات خارجيه
واستقبلت وفود وخبرات كريم وواضح انه الان
هي تعتمد على القتال المتحرك القتال
الموبايل مع كثافه نيران العرب الوحده
فيها حوالي اربع انواع من الاسلحه
سلاح الدوشكا المضاده للطائرات زائد سلاح
متوسط زائد ار بي جي زائد
دي يمكن تكون هي اللي ادت وقدره على تحمل
الجيش لكن المفاجاه برضو كانت في بدايه من
الطلقه الاولى والمفاجاه التي حدثت الجميع
يسمون الى اعمالهم والى الاسواق فوجئوا
بوجود
صراع في الشوارع مسلح
ودبابات
واستخدام
عيارات كبيره
دي يمكن تكون جعلت الدعم السريع يصمت امام
القوات المسلحه لكن الصمود الان بدا اليوم
يتغير الموقف قليلا
حتى تتفوق بالدبابات التفوق بالطيران
طائرات
الصاروخيه وهذه الثلاث عناصر هي المضاده
للمركبات الغتاليه نعم طيب انا هنا سؤالي
يعني كيف لهذا العتاد امام يعني كيف
استطاعت اذا قوات الدعم السريع ان تصمد
لثلاثه ايام
هو صمود طبعا باعتبار ان الجيش ايضا يركز
تركيز شديد في تحركاته وخططه
لانقاذ ومنع الخزائر وصل المدنيين دي طبعا
واحده من الكوابح لعدم حركه الجيش براحته
او باستخدام كل القوات اللي عنده يمكن
الطرف الاخر لا يراعي هذا الامر ولكن
القوات المسلحه مسؤوله فيها القائد العام
هو رئيس الدوله الان ولذلك هي مسؤوله عن
حمايه المدنيين عن حمايه المستشفيات
الحمايه المناطق الدينيه ولذلك لم تستخدم
كل القوى المتوفره من النيران ومن المراوح
العسكريا الان انت يعني ادرى بقدرات كل
طرف الجيش والدعم السريع ما هو العامل
الحاسم الان لحسم هذه المعركه وتوقف
القتال في شوارع العاصمه السودانيه
العامل الحاكم للطرفين طبعا هو من يتمتع
بطول النفس الوقت يعني عمل الوقت
والوقت وخطوط امداد جيده وتوفر له معدات
لوجستيه والطرف الذي يمنع الطرق الاخر من
التعزيز
ويمكن الحاجات دي متوفره للقوات المسلحه
تستطيع من الطيران انها تحيي اي تعزيزات
تستطيع ان تحيي زي خطوط لكن هو قتال المدن
من شارع الى شارع يضعوا فيه ايضا المقارنه
تضعف المعلومات
الان هي ضبابيه المعلومات الطرفين
المتصارعين وهذه القنوات الفضائيه وسائل
الاعلام طيب شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المداخله معنا الدكتور امين اسماعيل
المجذوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي بمركز
الدراسات الدوليه كنت معنا من الخرطوم
ايضا هو مشاهدينا المزيد من التصريحات
التي تتدرب فيها روايه الطرفين الان
المستشار السياسي للدعم السريع يقول
للعربيه ان قواتنا لم تستسلم للجيش ولم
تسلم
اسلحتها كذلك في حين قبل ذلك الجيش
السوداني كان قال ان اشتباكات اليوم كانت
محدوده وانحسرت في تامين القياده العامه
ومطار الخرطوم اذا مشاهدينا لليوم الثالث
على التوالي تواصلت المعارك بين قوات
الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش السوداني
الاقتتال انتشر في مختلف ارجاء السودان
سيما العاصمه الخرطوم وسط تضارب للانباء
عن سيطرته كل طرف
رقعه المعارك تتسع في السودان عده مواقع
باتت مسرحا للاقتتال سواء داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم او خارجها فخريطه الصراع مليئه
بالنقاط الساخنه اكثر المعارك شراسه تدور
رحاها بالعاصمه الخرطوم ابرزها مقر
القياده العامه للجيش والذي يوجد في شمال
العاصمه فالاقتتال مستمر في محيط مقر
القياده وسط انباء متضاربه حول الجهه
المسيطره على المبنى مبنى اخر في العاصمه
الخرطوم تحول الى ساحه صراع بين الطرفين
وهو مبنى القصر الجمهوري الذي يوجد في
المنطقه الشماليه من العاصمه ولا يزال
الوضع غير واضح هناك فقوه الدعم اعلنت
سيطرته عليه قبل ان ينفي ذلك الجيش
السوداني شمالا دائما لكن هذه المره في
الضفه الاخرى من نهر النيل وتحديدا ام
درمان حيث دارت اشتباكات في محيط مبنى
التلفزيون بعد محاوله قوات الدعم السريع
السيطره عليه لكن الجيش السود اعلن فيما
بعد سيطرته على المبنى بشكل كامل مجهضا
محاولات قوات الدعم وبعيدا عن العاصمه
الخرطوم وهذه المره في شمال البلاد
وتحديدا في مدينه مروي التي شهدت اندلاع
الشراره الاولى للازمه فمصير مطار مروي
الذي يقع في الجزء الشرقي من المدينه لا
يزال معلقا في ظل اعلان كل طرف بسطه
سيطرته عليها والاكيد ان حرب المدافع
والاسلحه في السودان توازيها حرب معلومات
اسلحتها المقاطع المصوره والبيانات
وسام الذهبي العربيه
والموضوع ان شاء الله غربله
حيصفى بين الجيشين
على خير وان شاء الله هنرجع للديمقراطيه
ولشي طيب حاليا الحاصل حاصل بين القوات
المسلحه والمتمردين بالواضح كذا يعني حتى
المواطن المواطن الان ملتزم منزله صاير في
السودان ده خلاف بين اساس الكبار يعني انا
بعتبروا وخلاف على السلطه وعلى الكرسي ما
كنا نبغى كده لكن بس فتنه
وحصل
السودان الجيش وهو الوحيد حيقدر على كل
البلد ولا ما اعتقد ان الاقدام اللي جاريه
في السودان هذه كلها مطامح ومصالح شخصيه
فقط يعني الاسباب كلها هي اسباب سياسيه
واسباب فيها اطماع في في الكراسي خساره
الشعب السوداني بس يعني
سلطه كراسي الان شهر رمضان عشره واخر من
رمضان الان الان يتقاتلون في سبيل الكرسي
السلطه كل واحد بده السلطه لحاله ما بيهمه
الشعب شو بده
يعني الشعب يكون توحدوا مع بعض ما بيهمنا
ولا من هويدا ولا الجيش ولا من الدعم يعني
شيء هيدا حرام والله العظيم بصير يعني نحن
بعضنا بنقط البات يعني
لانه يلي بصير مش صالح لاي مواطن الجنزويد
والجيش مع انه توافق بيناتهم كرماليات
الامن يكون في امن امن تام في السودان او
استقلال تام في السودان انا بتمنى يعني
لازم يوفوه باي طريقه لا ما فينا نتواصل
لانه ما في شبكه وما في انترنت كل شيء
معقول
كل شيء معطوه
ونعود للمتابعه اذا الان من الخرطوم معنا
الصحفي السوداني خالد الفكي مره اخرى خالد
اهلا بك معنا مره جديده اريد ان اسالك
بدايه اذا كانت هناك اي معطيات لديك
متوفره حول وضعيه الجنود المصريين
وكذلك مساله استهداف منزل السفير الاوروبي
وسياره السفاره الامريكيه
ابواب الدم السريع التي قالت انها انهم
امنون ومتحفظ عليهم
وانهم يمكن تسليمهم الى السلطات المصريه
بعد التنسيق والترتيب ولذلك فبالتالي الان
حتى هذه اللحظه المعلومات الوارده من مروي
بان هناك اشتباكات اندلعت في وقت قبيله
مساء اليوم وظهر اليوم وتبادل النيران
الصغيره فبالتالي اعتقد ان الان المصير
المصريين حتى هذه اللحظه وليس هناك
معلومات مؤكده وان كنت يعني اتمنى
في اي امريكا لان هذا يدخلها في ذراع
السلطه المصريه ومع القوات المصريه
المسلحه خاصه بعد الاجتماع الذي عقده
الرئيس السيسي اليوم ووقف على خطوات
وتقييم اجراءات كيف الافراج عن هؤلاء
المصريين الذين تواجدوا وفقوا بالدخول ام
عسكري بين القوات السودانيه والمصريه ولكن
بالنظر ايضا الى الخرطوم ومحاولات
الاعتداء على السفاره المصريه او ممثل
الاتحاد الاوروبي في
ان هناك طلب سائل يريد ان يضع المجتمع
الدولي والقوه الدوليه في صب هذه العقليه
السودانيه ويجعل هناك
ربما يجعل مدخل للتبديل الدولي في هذه
القضيه وربما يعني هذا يضع السودان
والدوله السودانيه في مازق جديد مع
المجتمع الدولي خاصه يعني الثوره يستطاع
ان تقلق الملف المتعلق بالجامعات
الاسلاميه والمتطرفين والعلاقه السيئه
التي كانت الى له قبل قرني من الزمان بين
الخرطوم والمجتمع الديري مما جاء المؤتمر
الدولي يفرض العقوبات اقتصاديه
الدبلوماسيه وسياسيه بسبب حكومه البشير
والسياساتها التي اتخذتها والادبيه التي
معرفه بها سلطتها في فتره حكمها فبالتالي
يعني انا اتوقع ان الحكومه ينبغي ان تطلق
يعني سلسله من التحقيقات الجريئه الواضحه
حتى لا تضع نفسها في ورطه مع المجتمع
الدولي سواء كان المتحده الامريكيه او
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتعلم صراحه عن النتائج
وعن من الذي فعل ذلك وما هو الهدف الرئيسي
وهل هذه الامر يتعلق بوضع ممنهج ام هو
عباره عن
من الذين يتعاملوا معهم وليس لهم سوء نيه
فيما فعله طيب ارجو ان تبقى معنا خالد كما
تتابعون مشاهدينا في العجله الجيش
السوداني يقول سنوسع نطاق العمليات ونطلب
من المواطنين الحيطه والحذر الدكتور اسامه
هنا اعود اليك واضح ان كل طرف
متشبث يعني بالقتال حتى النهايه
برايك في
في ظل هذا الوضع المتوتر الذي بدا يربك
الاقليم والعالم كذلك اليوم قلق اوروبي
كذلك استهداف للسياره امريكيه للسفر
الامريكيه طبعا اضافه الى الاجتماع الرئيس
السيسي بالمجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
برايك هل سيكون هناك
حل من الخارج برايك
الواقع كما اشرت
التحرك المصري وتحرك
الحدث ما بين
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في المجموعه
والحديث عن المرحله القادمه وايضا الاشاره
في الكونغرس الامريكي بانه قد يعودوا
للقرار الذي كان سيصدر ضد البرهان وحمايه
في 2021
قد يعني المساله تتصعد بعد هذا الحادث
الاخيره التي تم فيها لانه في عدم تقدير
موقف جيد في المرحله الحاليه من الطرف
الذي هناك
نيه للتشارك في السلطه بين البرهان وحميتي
هذه هي الرساله نعم هي هذه الرساله الجهه
التي تحركت بهذا التصرف
تقديره للموقف وفق لظروف الحاليه خاطئ جدا
جدا اي تحرك نحو اعتداء على اي
جهه خارجيه تعيش يعني لها ادوار داخل
السودان في المرحله الحاليه يؤدي الخطا
لكن دكتور دكتور اسامه يعني نتحدث عن
مساعي الحل عن مساعي الوساطه عن مساعي
يعني وقف اطلاق النار ولكن هناك
سيناريوهات اخرى يحكى عنها الان في
السودان هي اكثر قتامه ربما منها تكرار
السيناريو الليبي الان في السودان لانه
بالنظر الى شخصيه رجل حمتي والبرهان لا
يقبلان الهزيمه بالتالي نحن ذاهبون ربما
الى شرق وغرب سودان مثل ما يحصل في الشرق
والغرب الليبي هل هذا وارد هذا وارد اذا
ما تحركت
حركات المسلحه الموجوده في الخرطوم دلوقتي
حركه من نوي وحركه
مالك عقار وحركه
العدل ومساواه بكل ما لديها من قوه عسكريه
موجوده في الخرطوم اذا الامر اللي طلع من
دائره
الصراع ما بين القوات الدعم السريعه وقوات
المسلحه السودانيه
بدخول الحركات المسلحه الى الساحه مع طرفي
للاطراف الوضع قد يتفجر هنا سؤال مهم
الحركات المسلحه السودانيه هي اميل لاي
طرف في الوقت الراهن هي نعرف انها هي
الحركات التي وقعت اتفاقيه جبل السلام هي
معظمها حركات من اقليم الغربي من السودان
ولكنهم في الوقت الراهن هم مع البرهان في
ما يتعلق بالاتفاق الاطاري
ورفضهم للتوقيع كما نعلم البرهان هو عطل
للاتفاق الاطار الى حد ما اما دور الحركات
المسلحه الموجوده في الخرطوم دلوقتي
اشكاليه الكبرى هي حركات تتبع للغرب
السودان بشكل اذا تحور الامر الى
الى حرب مناطقيه او اقليميه بكل التاكيد
تلك الحركات ستنضم الى الجهه اللي هي تاتي
منها وهذه تكون مفارقه كبيره ومشكله كبيره
جدا على كل المستوي هي هي السيناريوهات
يعني
متوقعه ولكن نتمنى ان لا تحدث ونتمنى ان
يحصل السينار لربما الذي تحدثت عنه مديره
مكتبنا في القاهره انه يتوقف اطلاق النار
قبل عيد الفطر اشكرك شكرا جزيلا دكتور
اسامه احمد المصطفى انت الكاتب والمحلل في
الشؤون الافريقيه
وفي مداخله مع العربيه اكد المدير
الاقليمي للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في
افريقيا بان الوضع في السودان صعب وخطير
جدا
ممكن يصير كارثه اكثر واكثر اذا الوضع
الانساني ما استتب واذا
المجال للمنظمات الانسانيه خاصه العامله
بمجال الاغاثه الصحه المياه انه
تتدخل بطريقه سريعه جدا راح نشهد اكيد
انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم تسيير
المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف الشيء اللي
راح نواجهه قريبا
اذا مشاهدينا بهذا تنتهي هذه الساعه ولكن
التغطيه مستمره على العربيه لهذه
الاشتباكات في السودان في يومها الثالث
على التوالي الزميله راويه معكم في الساعه
المواليه الى كرويه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات